good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy hump day it doesn't
feel like a hump day because I'm so far
away from the girl whom I wish to hump
her name is Jackie and she's on the
other end hey Jax how you doing I'm
doing good at least we can be together
virtually on this hump day because we
weren't supposed to be plans have
changed around here it's true in case
you don't in Caso de que that's like my
favorite thing to say in Spanish
so much better than in case yeah
it really does so in Casa de que that
you guys don't follow us on Instagram
you're probably expecting to see a
gorgeous video and audio episode today
with Hannah burner I'm not feeling great
I'm actually feeling a lot better than I
was yesterday but I just need to listen
to my body like all the influencers I
follow tell me to do and that's exactly
what I'm doing I'm resting I'm drinking
tea I'm definitely on the mend but I
just needed I needed a minute
what am I eating
did I say I was eating you said that
you're resting drinking tea but you
omitted what you are eating which has
been in calcul
incalculable and making you feel better
oh oh
yeah we should talk about that so yes
okay I have fallen ill and it do we
think the timing is suspicious on Monday
after I ragged on soup I do I do think
it's suspicious yeah soup watching
Monday's episode side eye
literally that evening I'm like it's
kind of tired you know like I'm like
maybe I'm just you know I'm tired 100
yeah no soup was getting back at you and
they were like we're gonna show you
because now Claudia has fallen ill and
she's taken to eating soup and she said
not only is it very tasty but it's
making her feel better so I didn't say
it was tasty I didn't say it I think
they did I think that you did say that
when you and I were chatting on the
phone I was like by the way I'm not
feeling well but like I just had some
soup and I immediately felt better like
it was actually crazy so do you want to
take back your slanderous words about
soup and maybe they will lift the
illness sooner so that you can come to
Florida listen I didn't say anything I
said to stand by what you said or are
you gonna apologize I do stand by what I
said what I had said was that do better
you know I don't do better I said it
really does make you feel better like
it's so annoying because I don't love
the taste that's exactly how I feel I'm
never gonna apologize for saying exactly
how I feel I feel like you're a bit
harsher like soup is disgusting it is
but okay I think you learned your lesson
when I was drinking my consummate just
broth from 2nd Avenue Deli yesterday I
was like this is gross
okay
you're doubling down soup is going to
come for you soup is going to come don't
you want to get better I'm speaking my
truth I'm speaking my truth but you have
to get better because you're supposed to
come see me tomorrow and if you are sick
you can't come well I got an iv last
night I'm feeling much better what do I
have by the way what like what do you
have what else I don't know I just like
I have like exhaustion I have like a
little tickle in my throat that that
actually has went away I've been
drinking a lot of tea a lot of fluids a
lot of liquid ID I got an iv yesterday
um so I had like a little bit of you
could tell I'm like a little nasally I
don't know if you guys can hear like my
sexy my stickies the gay shows like that
kind of I'm
it's not super and easily though it's
not like you're congested correct oh
yeah like I'm not crazy sick I just like
you're run down run down run down I
wasn't feeling well so I did something
crazy I worked from home
um are you okay with your text messages
you want to meet your computer
I just put myself in do not disturb
because everyone just wants a piece of
me and that's just gonna happen every
time we do an audio on the episode it's
gonna happen once and then I'm gonna
turn it off it's not a part of your
routine to like mute your computer
before we start it is for me
part of me just feels like if I mute my
computer then like I'm going to be muted
even right now I didn't turn the volume
off on my computer I turn my my whole
apparatus on do not disturb
I'm always on do not disturb when we
podcast do not disturb it's like a
fabulous feature it's a fabulous feature
but when you have children you really
need to be available to be disturbed so
I'll be able to still see what's going
on anyways that's why it um it keeps
happening to me so I don't mind machine
me thanks
literally wasn't I think you were kind
of like on Mama shaming maybe I think
that's what you happen when you have
kids again
like that was a Vibe sorry don't twist
it don't twist it fair yeah okay cool
um in terms of tomorrow I am still
planning on coming I'll see how I feel
when I wake up like I do feel like if I
had to get on a plane right now I would
be fine I just like wouldn't want to
yeah okay so take it easy that's why
we're doing Audio Only it's so funny we
were like so excited to be back you know
maternity leave's over and now it's as
if I'm pregnant again and we are audio
onlying I I know it's so stupid I can't
say this enough times like how maybe
maybe five percent of our listeners
watch on YouTube like as long as you and
I get an audio episode up we like our
jobs are done like it's really just as
done as a regular video but I feel so
incomplete I hate podcasting from home I
love being in the studio I feel like I
do my best work yeah same something when
I'm like dressed up I look like a slate
I haven't washed my hair like yeah
getting up getting dressed by the time
we finish an audio only episode like I'm
just in a pool of my own sweat we are
just broadcasting is such a sweaty
Endeavor and I'm not a huge sweater so
it's like it's not like I just sweat
while I'm sitting but when I sit in
podcasts Audio Only not in my studio yes
I'll tell you why I'll tell you why okay
because when we podcast from home we're
using like pretty good mics but they're
not our studio mics so we turn off our
air conditioning like we make it a very
you know quiet environment so that is
why when we're done podcasting from home
we're I always have like literally a
line of sweat between my thigh and my
vagina okay just want to say I don't
turn off my AC I didn't when I was
pregnant because like I couldn't like I
would have overheated and now I don't
have noisy AC in my bedroom so it's not
the reason I think the reason is when
we're in like at least for me my
um Contraption of computer microphone
charger table on my bed is like all very
precarious and if I move it could all
crumble so I literally have to sit in
the same position for an hour straight
like and and it's not a smart position
it's like my legs are tucked up like I'm
sitting like Debbie style and then you
know I get sweaty behind my knees and in
every crease that didn't move for one
hour no that's that's true but also
another reason it could be
it's like all these devices like you
have like this microphone they emit heat
the computers emit heat they do also it
just would be
it just could be the very physical
nature of what we do of the work and if
we were in such gesticulators and
talking with our hands and so emotive
maybe we wouldn't break a sweat no but
maybe that's gesticulation it's the
gesticulation yeah I think so
we got to God we kind of got to the
bottom of that yeah so that's why we're
podcasting from home
um it's gonna be a great episode though
it's still Wednesday we've actually got
great stories of VMAs were on last night
I watched most of them and we have deer
toasters really good ones that we have
an update too
can't wait I haven't done a deer
toasters in a while I guess I've not
since before maternity leave so I'm
happy and excited to help our girlies
out I was excited to get Hannah burner
helping people I feel like she would
have given funny advice but I have
rebooked her everyone don't worry I
believe it's the first week of October I
can't remember exactly but she's coming
back don't worry like we gotta chat
great and he just got a little extra
Jackson Claude original recipe this
weekend will still be doing the show
together on Friday so it all works out
basically what we're trying to say is
that all's well that ends well
but I'm in a new hell every time I see I
wasn't gonna bring up that part because
I'm not in a new hell I'm with my girly
like it's just better than that it's so
true speaking of your girly we need to
address something yeah I literally we
both said it at the same exact time the
highlights from yesterday is what we're
going over and one of them was I sent
Claudia a gift to her home because I saw
these items online I felt that turdy
needed them they were so turdy and you
know me I like to just send a little
gift here and there when I see something
that makes me think of someone when you
see something you say something when I
see something I buy something yeah so I
send Trudy like a little care package of
things from Bloomingdale's because
that's literally her second residence
and one thing that they had was a
pickleball paddle they did a collab with
recess so I just was like oh these items
are so turdy I'm thinking of her sent a
little note in my order sent it off and
I was so excited for you to receive it
I opened my phone yesterday I go to your
Instagram story and she posts the
pickleball paddle saying thank you
Bloomingdale's in recess
okay let's start from the beginning I
immediately was like oh my God no I sent
you that but then I actually thought it
was such a turdy specific gift that
maybe they gifted it to you too and I'm
you know the schmuck who bought it for
you right so let me just tell you from
my POV okay like the aftermath of course
I'm humiliated that my first instinct
would be like oh my God the brands of
the world are trying to get to turdy
like I'm so self-involved like that
tracks I didn't even delete it because
it's so accurate of like how high I
think of myself honestly
second of all
in my defense
a few things like a week ago I had
posted that I wanted to get my own
pickleball paddle and like what brands
did people recommend so I figured like
this was a direct result of that
Instagram story first of all
second of all
I'm gonna blame Bloomingdale's here
their note system
Is Not Great you know how like when you
order online you get a return label it's
like printed on a sticker so you just
peel the sticker off and you place it
when you want to return stuff the note
was literally at the bottom of a sticker
I was like it looked just like gibberish
like a tracking number like I didn't
look at it I just threw it right away
yeah that's not right because I did
specify this is a gift I would like to
write a message and that's how it came
no yeah and like it was gift wraps now
that I think about it but I figured you
know the marketing department yeah they
want to put their best foot forward
and then furthermore there wasn't just a
pickleball paddle in there there was a
t-shirt that appeared to be like some
sort of merch for the restaurant that is
on the seventh floor of Bloomingdale's
called 40 carrots they have the best ice
cream in the city and I eat there
probably four or five times a week right
so I was like oh they obviously have
come to know me as a regular I never get
any special treatment there but I'm like
you know what I like kind of put this
place on the map like I'm actually I
didn't put it on the map I'm keeping it
on the map because it's always been on
the map and I'm just like oh it's so
nice to finally be recognized maybe I
can like you know cut a line here and
get a free ice cream I thought I was
really like becoming VIP at
Bloomingdale's 40 carats so I'm like Oh
my time has finally come I didn't even
question it
for my POV I saw the pickleball paddle I
would say Claudia has to have this and I
was looking there having like their 50th
Anniversary like Bloomingdale's Bazaar
where they had all of these Brands
design items that have the bloomgales
like logo or iconic Bloomingdale's
things it was like huge four pages of
things and like you are obsessed with
Bloomingdale so I went through every
single page like looking for the right
gift for you so I saw this 40 carats
t-shirt which you eat at 40 carrots
every single day she has to have that
and it's like really cute embroidered
with a Frozen new ice cream cone and the
pickleball paddle so for me I guess
that's how much it was like the perfect
gift for you that like yes so many
different people it was going to find
its way to you no matter the Avenue
well let me say and I feel like this is
most important thank you like you're in
the throes of postpartum hood and you're
thinking of me like I honestly I'm so
blessed like I really am you're such a
great sister it's such a great gift I
cannot wait I might bring my pickleball
paddle down to Florida with me in case
you want to play oh my God yes oh my God
but you're gonna just be so much more
stylish than me I just wanted to say
thank you like it's really it's an
amazing gift
now why we need to talk about like my
obsession with Bloomingdale's like why I
mean my obsession with the restaurant is
not even a question it is the Premier
restaurant I do have some notes for them
and every time I go in there I try and
like find a manager because I really
feel like they should start serving
french fries I think it would really
change like the landscape of
like they're known for like sandwiches
wraps and salads and what is better
what's more girl dinner than like a
salad with fries I really feel if they
had fries
the restaurant would like have a whole
new era I understand but I also
understand why they don't have fries my
issue with 40 carrots these days is the
quality control like so many times we'll
get lunch and it's like you can tell
this was not made with love but this was
actually made with hate it's really
disgusting like I'll get a veggie burger
on top of a like with my salad and the
veggie burgers like still frozen a
little bit so the lettuce is the lettuce
is Browning okay like literally sound
appealing there's two types of 40 carrot
seeds like the ones where it is the best
restaurant ever like everything is fresh
and healthy and good and the ones where
it was just made with hate hate yeah
food but I feel like if people like
aren't from New York or they haven't
heard of 40 yards like it's important
you know like when you and I were in
high school like there was not a cooler
better restaurant like it was in its
Heyday the place to be and it was always
delicious and now it's really just like
a lunch spot it's not a restaurant like
don't be making a resume
but it just has like a good menu and
like good energy I can't explain it but
it's like a very Jewish restaurant like
they serve like tuna salad chicken salad
egg salad like it's very Jewish and
in its Heyday like it was Supreme and
it's definitely not as popular as it
once was and like I feel very strongly
like that it needs to come back full
force I do think the french fries would
change the game for them and you know
what like okay I'll offer it my services
like they need to like collab with an
influencer like they need to do
something to get themselves back on the
map like I was thinking like last time I
was there I was like we need to have
like the turdy meal on the menu where
you get like a large Diet Coke uh my
favorite wrap grilled chicken Caesar
wrap
and a froyo on the side and it's like
sold as a meal kind of like Travis Scott
did it like Bloomingdale's I mean I
McDonalds like I really I I feel like an
investor in 40 carats maybe they'll let
you invest but
I don't know better I just don't
understand why I can't order a salad a
wrap in a froyo no you can you can but
it wouldn't be the turdy meal that's
true but the attorney like I feel like
when you're gonna do a custom meal it
has to be like a little more custom
no it has to be like a little better but
like I eat crab so that's what you're
gonna get yeah
no there's a lot that they could do and
they don't do and I just want to know
what the difference is between the days
where the food is made with love and
made with hate like is it a different
Chef like is it right is it just like
you know the last day of the groceries
and they're getting great delivery
tomorrow it's so true like when Jackie
was on bed rest but she was in New York
like pretty much three or four times a
week I would come over and bring lunch
because I was having lunch but like
either by myself or meeting a friend
always had lunch at 40 carrots and then
I'd be like Jack you want me to bring
you something because I was coming over
to her house anyway and I would
literally walk in and she would be like
was it a day that was made with love or
was it a day that it was made with hate
and like based on what you ate I knew
how mine was gonna taste and that was
always correct
so they just like need to like they need
to get it together I'm hoping that this
podcast can be some sort of impetus for
them to just
revamp
refresh refresh
and I know I know that it's called 40
carats and I know that like carrots are
a really important part of their brand
for some reason so they have to serve
every meal with that soggy carrot salad
but like I'm just here to tell you as a
brand like Enthusiast you don't like you
don't have to put that slop on the plate
you don't
damn but you do need to put the pretzel
rod
oh that's the other thing and one thing
they're known for like if you order a
salad they always serve it makes the
salad really tolerable they serve it
with like a really warm pretzel roll and
sometimes they're not warm these days
which is just unacceptable and now it's
just very much like a lottery you get a
salad there might be a pretzel roll
there might not be like it needs to be
more uniform and the pretzel rolls could
use a few more flakes of salt salt yes
and and maybe like they could offer a
dipping sauce on the side like a little
mustard
I really feel and like maybe it would be
who them to have like an appetizer
with like warm pretzel rolls with like
cheese like Mama's beer cheese now we're
getting like fat
okay oh yeah it is a healthy restaurant
so no beer cheese will not be on this
video okay whatever I'm just saying like
a little Ingenuity wouldn't hurt and I
hope that this podcast can be a catalyst
for somebody high up at 40 calories a
catalyst for change we're nothing if not
a catalyst for change and you know what
we'd be looking for
a carrot list for change
okay I actually feel really good that we
got that off our chests I agree I feel
like we need to get into the stories
yeah because that's what we're here to
do
so we can't be like taking off for time
we need her to rest and recover as
always the toast does have restorative
properties like I'm just feeling
I'm feeling good well that's the thing
about feeling not sick but when you're
feeling a little run or under the
weather sometimes
the stirring in it is like the worst
thing you can do and you've got to kind
of like Get Up and and urge your body
into moving forward like yesterday I
definitely needed to be in bed already
like that was dressed you're right maybe
like a little walk today yeah just but
don't overwork yourself but sometimes
you need to like coerce your body into
feeling better but only like not if
you're well and truly sick like do you
have a fever or anything no
the way I'm explaining it they're gonna
be like girl like why didn't Hannah
burner come on the podcast like you're
fine and like I'm not no she's not like
you guys I can't because I know that she
would never ask me to do a third episode
in a week like if she would never need
my assistance thank you Jackie I stand
with turdy and I would never ever
electively eat soup
so true and she you guys I saw her soup
she didn't even eat the noodles I know
was that crazy like the court but was it
the ozempic
oh you know what day is it today
Wednesday so it's due day it's Do or Die
day and I was thinking I'm like we'll
take myosmic make me feel worse or
better I wasn't chancing it though I
took it oh my God you're funny but also
you haven't had those like physical side
effects of ozempic like no and I don't
feel nauseous I haven't like thrown up
or anything yeah is it just so
liberating that we can just talk about
ozempic
in everyday life
yeah I think I thought it would feel
like a little bit more liberating I just
now I'm very conscious of like not being
annoying yeah well that's like every
time every day we have to be conscious
of that I know but every time I do talk
about it like I am you know being
painted as you know a murderer of
diabetics which is just of course
inaccurate I haven't seen it yeah oh
yeah
anytime I post like a reels or a tick
tock they're like your soda's good thing
hmm
but like
do your research or as I would say
educate yourself once again I stand with
30.
as one should anyone who doesn't salmon
30 is more often than not on the wrong
side of History it's so true history no
I can't speak for Trudy I can't speak
for truding history stands with dirty
no the more things
change the maternity stays the same
that's true look at you're still in your
apartment
shut up oh you know what I haven't
updated everyone what's going on because
I said I would devote my maternity leave
to
finding a new apartment and I did you
did oh my God she saw so many apartments
my husband kept meeting up with her to
like see Zach was so helpful honestly
and he's very good at like design like
furniture placement you know yeah
um I saw a bunch there were a few
contenders I actually ended up putting
an offer in on three of them
two of the offers were brutally rebuffed
one of them was accepted and I was like
in the process of like applying formally
when I realized like I didn't even like
the apartment and so I'm back to square
one I did end up extending my current
lease a little bit so I could have a
little bit more time so I I now have
like another month
um which was very gracious of my
landlord to do for me I'm still looking
I'm still looking and I like I'm so dead
set on seeing the snow by Christmas and
what's upsetting is the apartment that I
did get accepted for had great see the
snow by Christmas energy like the
windows and the views were beautiful
Wide Open Spaces but it wasn't me you
know
I do know so is there a chance that you
don't move at all
I mean there's always a chance of
anything you know but um no like I'm
committed I really am and I do want to
move it's like really important to me I
check every day okay
but you know the median the average rate
in New York City for rent
is fifty five hundred dollars that's
crazy it that's up like two and a half
thousand dollars from like a couple
years ago like it's crazy the market is
insane like you would die if you saw
some of the apartments that I've seen
I'm like I literally want to look the
broker in the face be like are you
kidding but then literally I got an
email the next day it's gone like people
are actually paying these prices it's so
crazy no I don't know what to do Jax
like
I don't know what to do
Florida's calling oh girl get out of
here
just think about it I'll set up some
tours while you're here
no I mean I'll move in with you I'm not
buying my own house that's like so
unnecessary you have a house Olivia has
a house I have to get my own house to
live in like my God just let me let me
live with you you could live with me but
honestly
why not no and your house is kind of set
up with like two really big bedrooms
yeah really two masters
no the thing is like I would do it in an
actual second we could never get the
boys to agree they'd be like this is so
stupid because they don't understand
Sisterhood and you know what they would
say they would say screw Sisterhood that
is that is the only hurdle because you
would do it
no of course and then I wouldn't even
need to have my own kids because I'd
have yours like it's everything it
honestly would solve all your problems
I'm obsessed and like all of our like
expenses would be split joint
we go to work every day upstairs yeah
Jackie we should have really like put
together a PowerPoint presentation and
then by the way like think of like think
of our our line of work like we would be
like those sisters who live together
like even people who don't know us and
their sisters and they live together and
they have a podcast like it's really
good you should listen like it's crazy
that they live together like and they're
married and they live together right
right right like and they share kids
like that would be our thing yeah I
think it would be really good for
business also not to get crazy but like
if we are doubling up and I'm happy to
have you move in with me and I would you
know foot the bill
of course for no reason just because you
don't want to pay but we could like look
into getting a bigger house
why we would have to go elsewhere let's
build an extension oh yeah we could
build an extension but no like now we're
like you know we can work for options
two budgets put together no see what's
out there
we should definitely this is so
compelling like we should just
definitely think about making like some
sort of PowerPoint presentation and I
don't like why why isn't it okay for
like married adults to live with like
their close friends or family like why I
don't know
I don't know and I it shouldn't have to
be like that much to convince Ben like
he could golf every day yeah I honestly
I think I'd have a harder time
convincing him to plunge into Florida
over living with my sister like he's
known me so long at this point like it's
not the craziest thing I've ever
suggested right but the plunging into
Florida part it's crazy that that's so
hard for him to ever accept because golf
yeah I mean but you know Ben's also very
family oriented his family lives here
like I understand but I do think maybe
there's something there and I'd I'd like
I'd say we'd come back you know to New
York once a month
but where would you stay would you keep
your apartment no that defies the
purpose if you're if you're letting me
live for free
yeah I'd keep my apartment
but that like really defines the purpose
because then why don't you just come on
down right now
and then we never have to tell our
husbands it's just a really long stay of
turkeys
right right right all right you know
what we'll flush out this idea we'll
keep working through it yeah but I love
I love where your head's at me too
are you ready for the fast five stories
that you need to know um today's episode
is also brought to you by ZipRecruiter
did you know that if you're an employer
who's hiring the average cost per hire
is forty seven hundred dollars if you're
investing that much money into each new
hire you want to get it right so what's
the most effective way for you to find
the best people for your roles it's zip
recruiter and see for yourself right now
you can try ZipRecruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com toast and experience
the value ZipRecruiter brings to hiring
so ZipRecruiter lets you try before you
commit there's no cost to try zip
recruiter you can post jobs for free so
you can see for yourself how effective
ZipRecruiter is at helping you hire they
also help you find more qualified
candidates faster once you post your job
ZipRecruiter smart technology Works
quickly to identify whose skills and
experience meet your match zip recruiter
will send you a list of available great
matches so your job
for for your job so you can review the
top ones and they're giving you the
power to zero in on top talent so if
you've got your eye on an excellent
candidate zip recruiter lets you reach
out to them directly so you can easily
send candidates you're really interested
in a personal invitation to apply it'll
help your job Stand Out amongst the
competition so whatever you're hiring
for check out ZipRecruiter it's simple
they help you get hiring right four out
of five employers who post on
ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day see for yourself go
to the exclusive link of
ziprecruiter.com toast to try
ZipRecruiter for free before you commit
again that's ziprecruiter.com toast
ziprecruiter.com
t-o-a-s-t ZipRecruiter the smartest way
to hire thank you zip recruiter for
sponsoring today's episode thank you so
much our first story is a little VMAs
recap the VMAs mtvs VMAs were on last
night and there's some big headlines
there were some big stars in the mix yes
there were yeah so first we had Justin
Timberlake and Megan the stallion
looking like they were fighting
backstage but a source says there was
Zero fight so this video like went viral
very quickly where it looks like Megan
the stallion and by the Timberlake
it really did look like that that they
were fighting yeah like they were having
words and Joey Fatone like his kind of
you know
Justin ran away which is so Justin yeah
so in the crowded area backstage Megan
is seen uh getting Glam On members of in
sync pass Justin smiling leans in to say
something to her and Megan responds
pointing her finger emphatically so it
looked like it could be an argument but
the source said there was Zero fight he
had said it's so nice to meet you and
she said no no this don't count this
don't count we gotta meet proper it was
very cute The Source says so I guess she
was just being emphatic about the fact
that like we need to meet she's
apparently a really big fan of Justin
and she posted a video with him after I
think maybe like an after party like
laughing about it so I believe that
there is no beef but when I was watching
I just like hate Justin Timberlake yeah
so I just assume everyone else says yeah
no and I assume the worst to him and
honestly I feel like last night was
actually like a really interesting
indication of where Justin Timberlake is
in his life because I feel like I is
Peak he got the video Vanguard award
like he
there was a time where people were like
he's the next Michael Jackson like he
was so and he in sync wasn't even the
[__] on his shoe to him like he was so
thought he was so much better than them
and I feel like he's definitely had like
a fall from grace not only did he just
like have a kind of a flop ERA with his
music but also you know those pictures
of him cheating on his wife like he's
just and and then the Britney stuff and
the every documentary paints him as a
monster so he's definitely in his humble
era and him getting back together with
NSYNC was a clear indicator of that not
only does he not think he's too good he
could probably use that sort of you know
Undying Love from America and I thought
it was interesting yeah so he reunited
with insync to present Taylor with her
award and she was freaking out I guess
she was a big NSYNC fan she should hang
out with Olivia
I literally can't with you
and if you don't know what dragon's
talking about feel free to read my book
it's literally so good and you will hear
about how diabolically insane Jackie and
Olivia were growing up about Nsync and
Backstreet Boys to the point where like
it tore our family apart and Jackie
clearly still holds some resentment to
Olivia for being like Queen of NSYNC
because Jackie was Queen of Backstreet
Boys yeah no just like if you're gonna
be into insane like you should talk to
Olivia because she's into in sync I
guess like it's always so crazy when
Taylor like Geeks out over people who
are just like
that was kind of not her theme that was
a major theme of the night because the
VMAs does this thing where there's like
a audience camera the whole time you can
watch feeds on mtv.com of like what
Selena Gomez is doing while Olivia
Rodrigo is performing and it's actually
very interesting
um
so we got a lot of content we saw you
know her Taylor Swift like singing her
heart out to Demi Lovato which I find so
interesting like tiller and I like were
similar ages like we all grew up in like
the Demi Lovato like we all know if I
ever did that I think I'd have a heart
attack like it's just so crazy to me
because like comparatively question mark
But then also there were so many
conflicting Dynamics at the um VMAs that
I was obsessed with like of course
Olivia Rodrigo and Taylor Swift like
Olivia Rodrigo can do as many interviews
as she wants saying there's no beef like
you will never convince me that there's
not there is no there is beef because
they were so obsessed with each other on
top of each other and now it's radio
silence
not only radio silence like Sabrina
Carpenter is like a Taylor Swift buddy
buddy she was sitting next to her all
night so then this Sabrina Carpenter
Olivia Rodrigo Dynamic I found very
interesting then Selena was there which
we love and we feel like we never see
Selena at award shows like this but now
she has her single I am single right
single soon so she's got to do the
circuit but like her and Demi Lovato
Demetria like there's beef there I just
felt like there were so many like I
wasn't expecting so many actual like
a-listers to show up yeah and I always I
always get surprised that um
Taylor like pretty much always goes to
the VMAs and I feel like she really
like wouldn't have to but then I was
thinking this morning like I feel like
she and she appeared to have such a
great time last night the fan cameras
were like staring at her the whole time
she was getting drunk she was drinking
red wine she was drinking about the soda
she was dancing like she was really
having a good time and I feel like she's
doing like everything to replace her
former memories of the VMAs like with
Kanye and that's why she goes every year
and when you think of it through that
lens like I kind of understand
um but yes it is shocking for her to
like geek out over people who are like
man
yeah I feel like she goes to like
certain award shows that might seem like
oh not somewhere she would go but
because she might have like a good
relationship with MTV just like with I
heart radio and she knows it's going to
be like a good environment for her and
she knows what to expect yeah and she's
like protected and it's also just about
like what she has going on at the time
like sometimes when she's in you know
quiet mode you won't see her anywhere
but like
you still gotta do yeah you have to do
the circuit you know the work the
industry she has to put in the work it's
the industry
it's the industry what other headlines
came out about
um so she swept the VMAs making history
with the most video of the Year wins
cool
anything else that you wanted to mention
um yeah I feel like when I watch the
VMAs I really realized like how
um little music I actually listened to
you know like obviously I knew like all
the pop singers but there's so many
other genres and like I just feel it
kind of makes me feel old
were there a lot that you didn't know
like so many K-pop bands I didn't even
heard there was like a category of
K-pop I had not heard except for
blackpink I had not heard of one of the
other bands like and the one who won I
hadn't even heard of oh wow
yeah it's just like it's a young girl's
game it is a young girl's game
it's tough yeah I didn't Kelsey
ballerini Kelsey ballerini was there
making
um headlines she came with Chase it was
her birthday they looked really cute
matching in red and she gave a gorgeous
performance of Penthouse and they were
making out on the carpet you know like
they're obsessed with each other like
it's nice but there was also rumors that
they had broken up
oh I didn't hear that I did don't ask me
where
oh my God Jackie are you like at the
center of the rumor mail um yeah I am
I'm really deep into it I hadn't heard
that they had broken up but they haven't
so that's good no they haven't going
strong happy birthday Kelsey it was
actually like a really fabulous award
show
um
like
and so many like actually like actual
Stars showed up which I just found
shocking I feel like
Selena like never goes to stuff like
that so it was fabulous this year she
also got memed like a thousand times she
like was just like kind of had like a
mug on the whole time and then she
posted on her Instagram story like
I'm tired of being a meme so like I kept
my face like that the whole time so you
guys like couldn't make and of course
they still did
that's unfortunate you just want to be
able to live so I like the idea of like
these fan cameras but it's really like
being in a fishbowl and then you think
that they're acting the whole time
because they know they're being watched
and no one wants to have like the wrong
reaction or they do want to go viral so
they have a reaction
it's just so funny like when Taylor
shows up somewhere like it becomes
Taylor Swift's Bat Mitzvah you know yeah
it must be like such a nice like benefit
of her life yeah I watched you're so not
invited to my bat mitzvah uh what did
you think I thought it was really cute
right yeah and it's really cute that
she's his daughter
so is the other daughter yeah no I know
but it's a movie's about Stacy and the
friend's mom I know is his wife is his
wife yeah yeah he's trying to make sure
you know yeah it was really
um it was really good it was funny it
was funny
and I like parts of it were so accurate
yeah me and Ben were like really dying
over Sarah Sherman like the conservative
female Rabbi obsessed no like that
person actually exists like I can't
explain it it was the way she dressed
like it was Perfection yeah I actually
Googled her because I she looked so
familiar but I didn't know who she was
and I thought she was so good and I was
like who is this person and she's into
SNL she's a new girly she's making
splashes she was really good yeah it was
cute I I thoroughly enjoyed it me too
um okay next story even though what I
wanted to say was the VMAs were like
canceled a few months ago because of
this no no the other ones were that was
movie and TV Awards which are sag right
because then I was like how are we
having an award show music totally
different who hosted last night
that's a good question like was there a
host was it Nicki Minaj No I don't know
huh
the world main number but actually they
don't have any writers
if there's no host and there's no
writers in there not violating the
strike right so actually I don't think
there was a host okay so now I could
segue into one of two stories and both
Segways would be really good but oh wait
also they're about to strike correct
strike adjacent okay I saw some people
saying like enough with the strike news
and I just want to know does everyone
feel that way because like I'm down to
stop talking about it I don't
particularly care well I I could go like
enough with the strike news when it's
like small updates about what France had
versus Bob but you know what now you've
chosen my segue for me because Drew
Barrymore is facing some backlash for
resuming her show amid the strike she's
been dropped as the national book awards
host after her talk show resumed the
strike so Drew Barrymore has been
dropped with the as the host of the
upcoming National book awards ceremony a
day after her talk show taped its first
episode since the Hollywood strike began
quote the national book awards is an
evening dedicated to celebrating the
power of literature and the incomparable
contributions of writers to our culture
the national book Foundation said in a
statement in light of the announcement
that your Barrymore will resume
production the national book Foundation
has rescinded Miss Barrymore's
invitation to host the 74th National
book awards ceremony oh my God reading
that statement I just have so many
thoughts like no it's like really kareny
first thought I'm available to host the
national book awards and I think that I
would be an amazing host for the
national book awards I agree however the
following things I might say might get
my invitation rescinded for me loser
behavior from like nobody asked the book
awards major loser Behavior who even
knew she was hosting them she keeps
getting all these hosting Goods taken
away from her no wonder she has to go
back to her show
a traversal thing that I'll say that
really I will not be hosting the
national book awards is that I don't
necessarily disagree with Drew
Barrymore's decision to go back to her
show and to resume production well the
interesting thing is is that she is
compliant this is not considered
crossing the picket line because she
will not have writers writing on her
show she will not have celebrities
coming on to promote projects like she's
following the rules so for her to be
punished when you could disagree with
her but in reality she is not crossing
the picket line for the books to get
involved I don't know how the books
apply here first of all like objection
relevance no because it's like writers
we support writers
oh like book writers okay yeah writing
connection okay I see the connection I
take that back
um but she's really not breaking any
rules I think you could argue the merits
you know ethically if you're inside you
could go on and on about what you would
do but at the end of the day she made a
decision I would love to know her true
reasoning for making the decision
because she doesn't seem like the type
of person to intentionally do something
controversial like no she's not a brave
person like that you know no so she's an
industry girly she plays by the rules
and she's very well liked and she
doesn't really you know she doesn't need
to she doesn't she doesn't make trouble
nor does she really need to she's got
like her her brand is being lovable so
right I think she has out of character
or it's in character and she has you
know good decent reasons for resuming
her show like there are a lot of other
there are a lot of people who work on
her show who won't be working like there
there's just so much that goes into it
and that see that's my question that
that's the question so it's possible
like she wants you know Pas camera
operators hair and makeup like she wants
people to get back to work and so they
can feed their families but if they're
in sag
how are they
working like I don't get at talk shows
quote and core talk shows actually I
think I know the answer to my own
question talk shows are their own
category it's like kind of similar to
unscripted a little bit where they are
technically not picketing but I think a
lot of shows are standing in solidarity
but they aren't required to pick it so
if you wanted to bring your show back
and bring back everyone except the
writers you could start getting all of
your employees paid and I have to
imagine that's why she's doing it or you
know the network said if you don't do
your show you're not you're going to
lose your show and it's not just about
her but it is about all those people who
are employed like I think she has
probably good reasons I choose to give
people the benefit of the doubt and not
just think that she's wanting to be
selfish and bring her show back also
this article notes that she employs at
least three writers who are members of
The Writers Guild and those writers are
picking outside CBS so it's not her
entire staff and I just think the
national book awards
I think they're wrong for this
interesting I
agree I think yeah like
I feel like Drew Barrymore did not do a
good job of explain she released a
statement yeah and I felt like her
statement was a whole bunch of [__]
like we released our show in sensitive
times where Global atrophy like I don't
[__] know like just just tell us like
what's the reason like you want people
to get paid I actually respect that
immensely and I think we're at a point
in the strike now where like
it's gone on for so long and it's really
really affecting people's abilities to
like keep you know
food on the table for their families and
sag is doing their best and I know a lot
of people have donated a lot of money
but there's like 100 000 people in Sag
and most of them are not rich so now
it's at the point where like they really
do need to strike a deal because
there's power of course in Striking but
at some point like people are gonna get
desperate and start taking non-u they
have to work right right that's what I
was thinking when we were talking on
Monday when you were saying it's going
to go until January
how can they go until January for
everyone
for everyone right
right
I don't know so I feel like we might
start to see more and more people who
are kind of On The Fringe of this strike
because also that's the other thing it's
like that's like yeah the lines of the
strike are a little blurry in terms of
like there's the clear thing like clear
intentions of the strike but then
there's other people who are like not
doing stuff in support of the strike but
not necessarily because it would be
crossing the picket line so I feel like
some of those people on the On The
Fringe or some of those projects might
start to resume because they will have
to
no and I think like Drew Barrymore is
just kind of like a Trailblazer in in
that actually it would be Jessica
Chastain because she like a few days
before was like starting drama with the
Menace Film Festival but it is
interesting to see like huge players
like Jessica Chastain and Drew Barrymore
doing what they think is best
yeah and it's important to know neither
one of them has technically crossed the
picket line people are just mad at them
yeah people don't agree with what
they're doing even though what they're
doing is completely in compliance it's
not it's not scab what's the word it's
not scab it's not scab it's just like
not necessarily in the most solidarity
with the strike right but that's more of
like everybody has to have nobody I
everyone has to have their reasons right
just we got their reasons
just like Drew just like true also these
are two people who very much play the
Hollywood game they're not right
controversial no so they've got their
reasons and I'm sure they make a lot of
sense and they're just doing a poor job
of explaining themselves Drew Barrymore
definitely did a poor job
but it's so Drew she doesn't talk in
specifics no she's so we launched our
show in sensitive times we've got a lot
of love right we have stories to tell
that's so true so true and one thing
about Drew Drew is gonna Drew Drew
Bieber
Drew B drewben I had one more thing to
say about oh not about the strike but it
just took my mind there did you guys
talk about Aaron Rodgers yesterday we
did
I'm in shock like I'm that just sucks no
no it's so Jets the one thing about the
Jets the Jet's gonna be Jetson like it's
the most Jets thing ever like the
loseriest team in the NFL finally gets a
fighting [__] chance in hell day one
minute one over obsessed no New York
it's so New York it's so New York and
it's it's really funny except for the
fact that like Aaron is extremely
injured of course you know it won't be
able to play but he will be getting his
45 million dollars don't worry I know
but you know Aaron no he's not like a
corner cutter no and he's not a money
grabber like I think he's in it for the
love of the sport
perhaps yeah right you really don't know
him that well no but the vibe I get from
him it's fair
because he was with Shailene
right and if you're with Chilean you
can't be in it for the money it's so
true
but I'm like we're foolish Lama Aaron I
just like that maybe like you don't
understand like honestly there's nothing
to say except it sucks
no it's literally the most depressing
thing ever especially like the first
game it was on 9 11 he ran out oh my God
show me the video American flag it was
like New York 911 Flag America
like it was honestly I watched it I got
a little teary I'm like I'm a New York
is back like five minutes later dead on
the field like dead literally it's so
it's so jet it's like you couldn't have
written a more New York Jets tale if you
tried yeah
I just I felt bad about that it's
definitely something to feel bad about
do you think Aaron like hates the guy
who tackled him
um
that's an amazing question actually like
no because I think it was like a totally
legal tackle but it's like the field was
slippery because it was raining was it
it was raining and like Aaron's just
kind of it's like a little older you
know maybe you can't withstand those
types of tackles I don't know or you
know the tackle just he came for his
Achilles his Achilles heal do you think
Aaron Rodgers is like in physical
therapy right now listening to State of
Grace because you know he loves Taylor
Swift yes I do
I could actually see him like I could
this is how I see it going down Kelly
teller wife of Miles good friend of
Aaron text him and being like
I can't even imagine how difficult this
time is for you I'm thinking of you I I
think this song would make you feel
better and she just sends him a Spotify
link to
um State of Grace and he's listening to
it during physical therapy getting his
stretches and he's wow this is a really
great empowering song and then the
bridge comes you're my achilles heal and
he knew all along why Kelly sent him
that song and it brings a tear to his
eye and he finds the Courage the courage
to heal in record time
getting back on the field next week
not next week but maybe maybe sometime
this season I feel like the Achilles is
like a career-ending injury it's not a
good one and I can't imagine and that's
why Taylor said you're my Achilles heel
yeah no because it kind of like takes
down the whole body but it also supports
the whole body it's that's the point of
being it because you see how it goes
both ways
um
but I think it would also be really hard
to like be it at the doctor's office or
like in physical therapy and having to
describe how about your heel without and
having to say the words my Achilles heel
without singing it if you know that song
you cannot say the word Achilles he
without saying maybe like Doc I'm
feeling a lot better but my achilles
heal still really hurts
so true so he's struggling with that too
breaking out into songs
and by the way that is something I've
you know historically struggled with and
if Aaron needs a shoulder to cry on you
know a mic to sing into I'm always here
for him because you know us New York
girlies got to stick together totally
oh actually my Aaron
referralima are you ready for our next
story if it's our next story that's
brought to you by modern fertility think
back to sex ed for a moment you probably
learned all about how to prevent
pregnancy but what about how to plan for
it we've always been big fans of
planning ahead you know scheduling trips
months in advance plotting out our next
career moves figuring out what we're
doing for dinner while we're still
eating breakfast but personally I've
never thought much about planning for
kids
we're supposed to go to the ob gyn once
a year for our annual checkups but
checking in with our fertility isn't
usually a thing we do until we're ready
for kids or if we're struggling to get
pregnant so the traditional guidance for
fertility has been just wait and see but
now we have tools to help us plan and
track for everything in our lives
Wellness financing career school so why
is fertility still a wait and see that's
why modern fertility was created it's an
easy and affordable way to test your
fertility hormones at home with a simple
finger prick mail it in with a prepaid
label and you'll get your personalized
results within six business days
so you'll get insight into your hormone
levels like your ovarian reserve AKA if
you have more or fewer eggs than average
for your age and other important factors
that can impact your fertility the
results will go deep into what every
hormone means and you can also download
the results to review with your doctor
for next steps traditional hormone
testing at a fertility clinic can cost
over six hundred dollars but modern
fertility tests are the same general set
of hormones for only 179 dollars plus if
you go to modernfertility.com toast you
can get 20 off your test plus you can
get reimbursed for the test through your
FSA or your HSA so if you want kids
today or maybe one day in the future or
clinically sound information about your
body can help you make the decision
that's right for you so go to
modernfertility.com toast to get 20 off
your test today's episode is also
brought to you by Dipsy picture this
you're hanging out in your favorite spot
headphones on and the world around you
Fades away when you're listening to
Dipsy stories you immediately become
immersed in a vivid world where touch
every breath every stolen glance is
spelled with breathtaking intensity so I
feel like one thing about me like I'm
gonna read smut and Dipsy is a fabulous
fabulous app full of hundreds of short
sexy audio stories designed by women for
women they bring scenarios to life with
immersive soundscapes realistic
characters you can discover stories
about Second Chance romances adventurous
vacation flings hot and heavy hookups
they have a lot of my personal favorite
Trope enemies to lovers they're
radically inclusive Dipsy has stories
for straight and queer listeners and 56
of stories are voice acted by people of
color you can now listen to spicy audios
by by your favorite Tick Tock creators
they're attentive to your every need
prioritize your pleasure and have voices
that will make you melt new content is
released every week so in between
listening to your favorite stories again
and again you can always find something
new and spicy to explore
they also have soothing sleep stories
Wellness sessions and sexy written
stories to read let Tipsy be your go-to
place to spice up your me time explore
your fantasies relax and unwind or even
heat things up with a partner for
listeners of the show Dipsy is offering
an extended 30-day free trial when you
go to dipsistories.com toast that's 30
days of full access for free when you go
to
dipsea stories.com toast
dipsystories.com toast thank you Claudia
not only do we need turdy's menu at 40
carats but we also need a turdy Dipsy
collab we need turdy's tails
dirty Tales
turdies Tails no like Dragon Tales
less than 30 Tales yeah no Dipsy is uh
audio smut and you should check it out
for sure our next story I can't believe
we're only on the third story we've got
to start making moves um
uh Travis Kelsey and Taylor Swift have
been rumored to be dating yesterday and
you know in the same day that the rumors
giveth the rumors taken away because a
source says that Taylor Swift and Travis
Kelsey are not officially dating
um ET has reached out to both Taylor and
Travis's reps to comment they have not
yet commented but there are rumors
circulating that they are spending time
together so we need to assess the rumors
I want to just put out there like I
don't think these rumors are true for a
multitude of reasons like he came out a
little too thirsty a little too publicly
like that's not Taylor's way of dating
like she's just not like that so I don't
think these are true for that reason
also in his literal most recent podcast
episode he's wearing a John Mayer tour
T-shirt If he had been quietly seeing
Taylor Swift that's the last thing
someone would do
looks like maybe he didn't know I don't
know but no I think that they're not
dating just like for different reasons
but I still also think they're not
dating like first of all I just don't
think that Travis Kelsey has the
sensitivity to like put together the
John Mayer
t-shirt thing like I think they could
have been dating and he could be wearing
that T-shirt and just not realized he
seems like that sort of guy the reason
why I don't think they're dating is
because I don't think that they would be
compatible or like each other or they
are each other's type
on it their face on its face right like
the main reason I actually didn't
believe the rumor is because it's quite
possibly too good to be true like Taylor
Swift is dating someone who's actually
handsome no like no no somebody who's
like big and buff and American no we
know who she likes like she likes like
Maddie Healy she likes like skinny Joe
always like Brit that's not her type
it's quite literally too good to be true
trust and believe I would love
absolutely nothing more I didn't even
get excited about this for one second
like it's so fraudulent no it's so
fraudulent it's so crazy how she could
really date anyone that she wanted like
she could she could literally date like
if she wanted to like like Prince
William like hypothetically if you were
single you mean yeah yeah yeah yeah
no man too famous or too handsome for
her she is the most famous woman in the
world and she is breathtakingly
beautiful yeah and it's like she could
get a date with anyone what happens
after that date and if they want to go
on a second one with her that's you know
she has to figure that out but like she
could call up anyone in the world and
get a date and I just don't think that
it would be Travis Kelsey which is I
can't relate to that no I mean they're
late
um but it's not gonna be him
honestly I ship but you know what else I
really ship Taylor and Jason Kelsey
why do you keep putting her with married
men dirty like I do not support women
because it's a fun hypothetical game
it's a fun hypothetical game I'm having
fun
you're having fun breaking up families
I'm having fun being a homewrecker
that's cool who do I see Taylor with
that's the hard part about this game is
that it's actually very difficult to
visualize her with someone the hard part
about this game let me tell you the
truth is having the brain span to think
of everyone that you're trying to think
of you know I like forget everyone who's
like single and eligible like my brain
goes blank
when I try and think about eligible men
of Hollywood I do have my list though
she's never Joe manginiello
um no he's too big yeah she's never gone
for an athletic type she goes for actors
and singers who tend to be thinner
honestly
okay Claudia Josh Groban
I mean like
let me just say let me just say
that couldn't happen
because things that good and that
perfect don't happen to people like us
like it's true
it is perfect
therefore it could never be yeah also
I'm on my list I need to take Chris
Evans off
you do there's a few people who are like
in relationships right now but they're
not leaving like Tom Brady did you put
Joe and Sophie on the list oh my God no
I didn't that's and I just want to go on
the record and say like I don't ship
Taylor Swift and Joe Jonas like
everyone's like they're both single uh I
don't care yeah I agree but I'm adding
him what about Jeremy Allen White and
Taylor Swift
there were rumors that he might be
seeing Selena which you know the girlies
don't girly like that
Selena you mean yeah yeah okay
okay
and also Jeremy Allen White is seeing
someone
cool
like he's been spotted out with like the
same girl like making out on run in
Canyon a few times
oh that's real I mean he's not married
so you don't have to take him off the
list but then you're not gonna consider
him
right right because he's not married
right right right right right
no I don't know who the right man for
Taylor is what about Aaron Rodgers even
though again he's an athlete but he
likes her music wait that's an amazing
call
and I don't think that Taylor and
Shailene are so dissimilar
but see here's the thing
the thing the last time Taylor dated
someone was Maddie Healy and I do feel
like a big part of their breakup where
people being like triggered because he's
like kind of you know a free talker like
he just says what's on his mind and
Aaron Rodgers is kind of like that too
he's very like America I think he's like
you know has some strong opinions on
some hot topics and I feel like Taylor
is not in the business of doing that
again like getting dragged into like you
know hot button issues because the
person she's dating like has you know
some some hot tanks on topics he's a
free thinker and it has some hot topics
yeah okay fine except
I do well like refuse to believe that
that's why when they broke up because
that would just be like incredibly
[__] losery that like she let her
personal life like she's really into
this guy and she's gonna actually like
let you know public perception affect
her life I don't think that's the case
me neither but I can't imagine that was
very fun
no or maybe I don't know maybe she likes
a bit of danger living on the edge yeah
Edge adjacent I just want to say I
really like her and Aaron Rodgers me too
but like she travels so much it's hard
to date an athlete they travel a lot not
anymore
true we just got the whole year off
and that's the song he would walk down
the aisle to at the wedding because it
was his Achilles heel that brought him
the love of his life and do you think
that she should sing him down the aisle
I know you're again sad in general but
if it was Taylor
I'm still against it who could sing her
song
me
turdy May 30 students wait what's up
from Legally Blonde of course when she
gets Professor Callahan's internship
thank you thank you and he then he says
screw Sisterhood how dare he
Terry
okay we need to move on to our next
story which will take two seconds I like
how you're like attacking me like I'm
the one holding us back I'm not
attacking I'm attacking the show and I'm
tagging myself honestly it's a
self-loathing sort of thing jugging it's
not worth it yeah but this story will be
brief Dancing with the Stars cast
announced okay season 32. wow
all good things at some point must come
to an end but it's not good anymore it's
not gonna be now because it's back on
ABC
oh and Disney plus like it's more
platformed than ever and these are the
stars that we'll be dancing
we heard about Ariana Maddox and
yesterday you guys talked about Jamie
Lynn Spears and charity Lawson The
Bachelorette were already
now we also have Mauricio umanski Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills star and
husband ex-husband of Kyle Richards
singer Jason Mraz actress Alison
Hannigan Mira Sorvino NFL player Romy
Romy Romy NFL player Adrian Peterson
Brady Bunch star Barry Williams
supermodel Tyson Beckford
and
Harry jouzy Lele pons and Matt Walsh
the only person of extreme interest here
to me is Mauricio umanski I don't think
we've ever had a house husband on before
right I would imagine
um Mauricio's like far too busy being
like actually successful in business to
be on a show like this like I find this
shocking
I find it shocking not the idea of him
being on Dancing With the Stars I think
that's a cute idea I agree he's a busy
businessman but maybe I don't know he
pushed all his calls till next month
um
but what's shocking is that how much
like front-facing interviews he's going
to be have to be doing at the weirdest
time in his life when he probably
doesn't want to be speaking on stuff so
why would you put yourself in the Lion's
Den where people are just going to be
asking you questions about your
relationship all the time like maybe do
Dancing with the Stars next year or
maybe have done it five years ago like I
just think it's really weird that he
would choose to do it now because he's
going to have to be talking about what's
going on in his life every single week
yeah like he's throwing himself in the
center of the drama right they've been
trying to avoid it
so I think that's weird but also the
fact that he's a businessman in doing
the show don't forget that he has his
other show and so now like doing stuff
like Dancing with the Stars is just part
of his job that's true I forgot that
he's like a dual reality star he also
has a Netflix show which is so crazy
yeah
um
I do not feel compelled to watch but
that's not or different or out of the
ordinary from any other season of
Dancing With the Stars
um wish everyone the best there isn't
like a clear maybe it's Lele pons
who you think would win like there's
usually a clear winner where it's like
someone with a lot of social media
followers and who can like already kind
of dance
yeah does Lily dance though or does she
do comedy she does comedy but she's like
a young fit active person she's Latina
so she has like the be you know yeah you
know who I feel like she would probably
win I feel like Harry dousey could do
well too well the bar for like a man to
do well on the show is so incredibly low
yeah but I agree
or maybe Ariana Maddox but I agree
there's not someone who you know has
been training and dance their whole life
Heather Morrison from Glee Charlie
demilio right right Charlie a gymnast
remember Laurie Hernandez yeah
yeah yeah there's not a clear winner no
um and you know what let's just make a
prediction just so we can look back on
this when someone wins read me the list
one more time oh wow okay
Mauricio Jason Mraz Allison Hannigan
Mira Sorvino
Adrian Peterson Barry Williams Tyson
Beckford Harry jouzy uh Lele pons Matt
walls zochito Gomez Ariana Maddox
charity Lawson Jamie Lynn Spears
I'm gonna say Lele pons
I like that for you she's like tens of
millions of followers
I'm gonna say
I don't know maybe charity Lawson
good
they love a bachelorette winning they do
but the bachelorette brand like doesn't
have the pull it used to have like back
when Hannah Brown and Caitlyn but just
wait till the golden Bachelor
it's gonna change everything it's gonna
change everything
did it start yet
I don't think so but you saw that
James's mom is on it
I did see that and I forgot that I saw
that but it's beautiful so cute so cute
are you ready for our fifth and final
story I am it's a little TV news because
the trailer for Kardashian season four
has dropped and the trailer is
trailering because it looks really
[__] good and in the clip Courtney
and Kim are on the phone and what looks
to be a heated conversation the sisters
are in the midst of an explosive
argument and Kim asks are you happy
you're a different person you hate us
we're just all talking about it then
Courtney responds while choking back
tears saying to Kim you're just a witch
and I hate you
not the witch that's like so much
crazier than [__] yeah witch the the
trailer does look good it also appears
that they're like you know altering
they're turning turnaround time a little
bit more
um it feels a little current and I think
that they kind of split their last
season like I think what they're filming
now is us when we're watching the last
episode no I don't think so I think the
reason why this feels more current is
because it's like more behind the scenes
stuff that they tease where it's like we
don't know when this happened right
because last season ended at Christmas
I'm sure they like took a little break
and then this is probably like January
February whereas we watched this in
their season in May
oh but Courtney's pregnant so oh right
she announced her pregnancy when in like
May
so MIA maybe maybe
or maybe that's the end of the season
you know right right well it still looks
good
um but it always looks good yeah it does
always look good they do a really good
job of teasing stuff but that one
conversation looks worth the whole show
yeah no and it is interesting to know
like we're still following along that
storyline and that's not a storyline I'm
fatigued of yeah like there definitely
is weirdness between them and it still
feels like when we follow them on social
media currently like it does feel like
there's weirdness yeah
so Courtney's like never with Kim she's
never like they both are like never
promoting each other's [__] like there's
just a weird mess
yeah but it's just like that can't be
because the family has to stay strong so
we have to work through it everyone
it also looks like we get like a decent
amount of Kylie yeah Kylie's talking
about how she feels more like herself
than ever she's in such a good place I
love Kylie content I always wish we get
more so hopefully she'll be pulling her
weight this season
I hope so and if she's really feeling so
great like
take us along and maybe like some
timothay Timothy Charlemagne perhaps
perhaps anyways I'm excited Premiere is
September 28th on Hulu pretty soon so I
appreciate I feel like it doesn't feel
like a lifetime away I yeah I feel like
the last time it was months months I'm
like I don't know what I'm where I'm
gonna be then I can't get excited about
stuff like that literally okay let's get
into Deer tursters dear tursters is
brought to you by seed there are over
3.8 million posts on Instagram tagged
hashtag gut health a staggering 650
million videos on Tick Tock and a quick
Google search will yield you over 30
million news results gut health
probiotics and the microbiome are
buzzing in conversation headlines and
hashtags discoveries in microbiome
research are transforming medicine
hygiene diet and the choices we make
make each day for our health with this
new frontier however comes an overload
of information and misinformation that
can feel overwhelming so like gutmania
over here but seed is here to help seed
is a microbial Sciences pioneering
applications of bacteria to impact human
and environmental health they develop
scientifically validated clinically
studied Next Generation probiotics for
people and the planet their first
product for humans the ds01 daily
symbiotic is the only probiotic we trust
and take if you've taken probiotics
before and haven't felt a difference
it's likely because the capsule isn't
designed to survive your stomach acid
bile salts and digestive enzymes seed is
different
now more than ever it's important to
trust science and integrity when it
comes to learning about and maintaining
a healthy microbiome seed is the company
that we trust so it's a plant-based
Prebiotic and probiotic with 24 strain
that has been clinically or
scientifically studied for its benefits
it's free from 14 classes of allergens
that are defined by the efsa so the the
seed ds01 daily symbiotic is helping you
avoid gutmania head to the trusted
source for symbiotics start a new
healthy habit today visit seed.com
toasts and use code toast to redeem 30
off your first month of seeds ds01 daily
symbiotic that's seed.com toast use code
toast all right our deer toasters today
are very interesting we have two
submissions and we have an update from
the girlies so first up is a little bit
of literature controversy which we've
never had before
hello Jackson turdy I recently published
a book under a pen name that no one
knows about it's not an overnight
bestseller but the book is actually
doing pretty well so far I've kept it
completely separate from my personal
life with only a handful of people who
know about it at all not even all of my
family knows about it
I was raised very religious with a huge
emphasis on Purity culture the thing is
my book is a spicy dark romance
featuring a plus size main character I
feel like I'm just waiting for someone I
know personally to recognize me on my
author's social media and expose
everything I was considering saying what
the hell and just announcing the book to
everyone to get it over with but then I
told my mother and she cried things are
a little better now and she's being more
supportive but it makes me second guess
if I want to deal with the Judgment of
other people knowing should I just
continue living my Hannah Montana double
life love a secret author toaster
ooh I feel like whichever path you
choose like is you know good this is a
good ultimately a good thing like you
should be so proud that you wrote a book
um you shouldn't be keeping it a secret
based on like shame though you know like
you should be proud of this and I think
it's best that you like told your mom
first and I'm in time I'm sure she will
come around to the idea probably just
was like a little shocking what because
it's like racy
yeah so she's very she said grew up like
Purity culture so I'm assuming you know
no sex till marriage you know we don't
talk about that kind of thing right so I
would give her some time but if if it's
important to you to like put it out
there with your name and everything and
take ownership of it then you should do
that but I feel like you went to such
lengths to put it behind a pen name and
and to kind of have a Hannah Montana
double life which I I actually think is
a nice thing in general not just because
you wrote a spicy book but because to
have some like delineation and some
privacy and that way you could write
whatever you want because what if you
know there's other issues with writing a
book what if people think it's about
them what if someone's offended you know
what I mean so you gotta kind of like
have the perks of like getting your art
out there but protecting your privacy
and your peace so I would just like
really look Inward and decide what do
you want do you want to claim ownership
of this book or do you want to have the
freedom to like have nobody in your
business right and then do what feels
right too because you're not doing
anything wrong you know you're not
hurting anyone the cool thing is that
like romance novels are having like such
a a Resurgence and they're so popular
and I think you'd be surprised like
probably some of your religious girly
swirly friends are like out here reading
smut like it's kind of this
um thing that used to I really feel like
there's a whole episode of Friends about
like Rachel's reading a smut book and
it's like so crazy like it really has
been destigmatized not to the point
where it's like totally
to the point where it's like completely
empowering but it is less so I think
Jackie's right like what do you want do
you want to be proud and like be able to
like post on your with your face I have
to imagine marketing a book is very
difficult when you can't
use your real name or make videos so but
there's also a lot of freedom afforded
with that so like if that's what you
want you just have to decide what you
want Jackie's totally right there's no
bad option here yeah but once the cat's
out of the bag you can't put it back in
so just consider that
just consider that yeah I like the idea
of a pen name it it leaves a lot of
mystery you can write whatever you want
yeah
the thing is when you come out you can
never go back if you're if you're
private like you can always come out
right it's like really you know after
years you're like desperate to come out
then also there's all this build up so I
don't I also don't think you need to
make a decision today yeah
but you will send us a copy yeah oh send
one to turdy turn it to his Tails she'll
read it for Disney
tour details
um there's no bad decision here are you
really like neither one of us can answer
this for you it's just like what do you
want follow your heart
you get what you want and this winter
break you want 30. I mean everyone are
breaking spring summer and fall
okay hey girlies I need your help I need
to decide if I'm being crazy or if I
have grounds my boyfriend in five years
forever P John has gone away to Europe
to travel for over two months I couldn't
go because of work we have a joint
spending account that we use for
groceries bills Etc we live and have a
mortgage together he told me that he was
surprised I was still using the joint
account for groceries and household
things while he was away because he was
using his personal expenses to travel
he even said quote so that means I'm
paying for half of your food that I'm
not eating am I crazy for getting upset
that he thinks I should fend for myself
while he decided to go away and travel
or am I being dramatic is this a hill
I'm willing to die on uh duh it's giving
Cheapskate like no let your girl eat
home is home like home is home why do my
habits have to change because you
decided to gallivant around Europe for
two months and yes technically like if
we're getting extremely mathematical
quickly yeah you're paying for your food
so I'll pay for my food but like
um hello like it's called chivalry and
just like let me eat and also if you
didn't have a conversation chivalry like
she's still home yeah no and if there
wasn't a conversation before about how
let's start you like use our personal at
this time which I think would be kind of
extreme like and unnecessary
if there wasn't a conversation the fact
that he would expect you to just like go
and use your personal is it's just like
rude and unnecessary sorry plus like
he's gone home home is home and you know
what like yes if we were to whittle it
down go back and forth with this guy
like sure do you have a point yeah I
guess do I literally care No [__] I'm
home you're traveling like that's your
[__] problem I'm not changing my way
always home home is home like home
things or home Tings yeah no I'm not
changing the credit card on my instacart
account
adding a new card
no I'm not doing it I have one thing to
say
home is home yeah that's a little
you know
small like that's small small agreed
it's getting small
especially it's home it's small
especially because they're together five
years they have a mortgage like they
have a very it's not like she's been out
like pounding the joint account yeah no
she's
to eat
no and it's not even like she's going
out to restaurants to eat like she's
buying groceries also like what if
someone she said household things paper
towels what if some of those groceries
are gonna still be there when he gets
home and he's got a big role of toilet
paper yeah but what but the few roles
that she used while he wasn't there
maybe she should pay for just those
venmo and start recording how many rolls
she used like that's what I'm saying
it's just small like small
you want to get in the nitty-gritty no
you don't
yeah cause we'll go there yes so then
she should cordon off all the groceries
that she bought by the time he gets home
and he can't go in that section of the
fridge
also are we going to talk about how he's
going away for months yeah that's a lot
two months in Europe
yeah like clearly
he's not you know broke because you
can't go to Europe for two months if you
don't have any money so money's not
really a factor for him on his big you
know gallivanting around town Europe so
calm down yeah
and I was like don't I don't know if
he's away he should want you to be in
every Comfort not like fending for
yourself
hunting and Gathering your own food
literally making your own toilet paper
so so all this to say you have grounds
oh you're not crazy grounds granted and
fight harder just keep using the joint
yeah no and you know what get yourself a
little something nice and if he has a
really big problem with it he should
come home
yeah we could talk about it at home yeah
Jeremy I don't have long distance
minutes can't talk right now
ctrn
TTYL all right our third and final dear
toasters is a submission it was actually
a really um hot button one a girl had
written in a few weeks ago that she and
her husband were expecting their first
child they tried for a year so they were
really excited and they were talking
about names and her husband let her know
that he wanted to name the baby after
his high school girlfriend first love
who tragically passed away their senior
year while the girl understood the
sentiment she did not want her to name
that and his mom said just like settle
with a middle name like it's weird but
do what you got to do here she wrote in
see the thing is there's always more to
the story Jax ready
hello Jackson turd congrats on your new
baby boy and welcome back we've missed
you speaking of babies I've got an
update for you ladies I was a girl whose
husband wanted to name their first baby
girl after his first love who passed
away while they were in high school
after speaking to him countless times
about it he finally opened up and told
me one of his Biggest Secrets his high
school girlfriend was actually pregnant
when she was killed they were the only
ones that knew his first Love's middle
name was Elizabeth and they had
discussed giving their baby had it been
a girl the name Elizabeth after crying
about it together I agreed to do a spin
on the traditional name I also wanted to
name her after my grandmother so without
further dudaru our baby girl's name is
Margaret Eliza she'll be called Maggie
for short I can't wait to meet her in a
few weeks oh my God that gave me chills
I know see the thing is there's always
more to the story like sometimes people
are not like saying wacky things for no
reason like right it's so true I think
Eliza for Elizabeth is so beautiful I
mean maybe her name started with an m
whatever it is I that literally gave me
chills when you read the name
wrapped up with a bow on top see the
thing is communication is never a bad
route to take ladies Maggie
Maggie Margaret Eliza but they're
calling her Maggie
yes I love the name Maggie you do I call
Margo Maggie and like I call Margaret
fish Maggie like I love the name Maggie
love it wow what a great way to end the
show happy for you totally all's well
that ends well period
exclamation point
and that's our show a gorgeous long
episode for you guys hope you enjoyed
tomorrow I'm still the schedule's up in
the air so just you'll have to wait and
see for tomorrow I am feeling better but
um we'll figure it out you need to rest
today right
the rest of the week will be there will
be shows there'll be crowds in there but
we will be shows yeah but who knows when
and where
you guys so much for listening to the
testimony Morning Show where we deliver
the past five stories you know everybody
through Friday on YouTube so if you're
watching this on YouTube please don't
forget to subscribing this video a
thumbs up we're also available
bye
[Music]